سوريه رئاسه مجلس الشيوخ الواجب الدستوري
الوحيد لنائب رئيس الولايات المتحده الصفه
السوريه لان صوته صامت لحين الحاجه لكسر
تعادل الاصوات طالما ان مجلس الشيوخ لديه
رئيس مؤقت ينتخبوا من اعضائه ويمتلك
الصلاحيات المرافقه للمنصب لكن نائب
الرئيس يقف ثانيا في خط الوصول الى سده
الحكماء في حال وفاه رئيس البلاد او
استقالته
فعقب اغتيال الرئيس ابراهام لينكين عام
1865 خلفه نائبه الديمقراطيس جونسون ليصبح
الرئيس الامريكي السابعه عشر غير ان
خلافات جونسون مع الكونغرس بسبب انتهاكه
لصلاحيه منصبه او صلاه الى بدء اجراءات
السحب الثقه منه في العام نفسه قرار لم
يمر بمجلس الشيوخ بفارق صوت واحد وحافظ
على منصبه لحين نهايه
بعدها بمائه عام تقريبا شغل سبيرو اغنيو
منصب نائب الرئيس تحت قياده شركه فصول
الفساد اغرقت اغنيو الذي اجبر على
الاستقاله عام 73 ما دفع بالرئيس نيكسون
الى تعيين الجيرالد فورد نائبا للرئيس
بموجب احكام التعديل الدستوريه لكن في
العام التالي اوقفت فضيحه
نفسه الذي استقال قبل بدء اجراءات عدله
اشرف
[تصفيق]
ابدا
لرئيسيه مجلس النواب او الشيوخ الا انها
اقتربت منها احيانا الرئيس مجلس النواب
قال البرت وقف مرتين في الترتيب التالي
للرئاسه بعد استقالتي اجينيو ونكسون لكن
تعيين فورد نائبا للرئيس ثم صعوده مباشره
الى مكان نيكسون دون انتخابات في المرتين
ابعد الفرضيه